[Music]
on this Friday night quarantined in
Canada hundreds airlifted from China
settled into their temporary home at a
military base first thing I did just
went in lay down in the snow and smelled
the like fresh Canadian air plus
warnings of a chronic shortage of
supplies the bill for trans Mountain now
billions more than before what's driving
up the cost of the taxpayers pipeline
it's like a horror movie the mob of bats
forcing a town into lockdown and icy
reception to a severe storm you have to
trip off your car yes
took me like a half hour and I broke two
my scrapers the miserable mess in the
Maritimes
global national with Donna freezin
good evening of thanks for joining us
hundreds of Canadians who spent weeks
stranded in the heart of the outbreak of
the new coronavirus in China are now
back on home soil two planes carrying
215 passengers have touched down at
Canadian Forces Base Trenton in Ontario
they'll spend the next two weeks at that
base under quarantine being monitored by
medical staff to see if they develop any
symptoms Chinese media is now reporting
there are more than 34,000 confirmed
cases and more than 700 people have died
the bulk of those are in China outside
China the single largest group of
confirmed cases is on a quarantine
cruise ship in Japan 61 people on board
have tested positive including seven
Canadians thousands of passengers on two
other ships are also caught up in this
outbreak one ship is under quarantine
the other is stranded at sea after being
barred from docking in Japan because of
fears passengers might be contagious
we'll bring you the latest from those
ships in just a moment but first to CFB
Trenton where more than 200 people are
settling in for a two-week wait under
quarantine
Global's Jeff sample is there for the
174 passengers on board this chartered
flight stepping on to Canadian soil has
rarely felt so sweet with me I just went
and lay down in the snow and smelled the
like fresh Canadian air and just enjoyed
the snow falling this Montreal family
snagged four coveted seats on the
government flight sent to pick up
Canadian passengers from the epicenter
of the corona virus outbreak boarding
the plane obviously we're in contact
with Armed Forces volunteers that were
there to help us evac and then it became
much more stringent passengers were
screened for symptoms before they
boarded in wuhan then again when the
plane stopped to refuel in Vancouver and
again after finally arriving at CFB
Trenton but their journey home isn't
over yet
CFB Trenton is Canada's largest air
force base they fly search-and-rescue
missions out of here and international
deployments to places like Afghanistan
but for the first time in its near 90
year history
CFB Trenton is a quarantine zone
the passengers must now remain on base
mostly confined to their rooms for two
weeks to see if symptoms develop a lot
of concern a lot of worry rich favish
'as toddler was with her grandparents in
Wuhan when the outbreak hit
he's been scrambling to get her out
there's a feeling of helplessness his
daughter was put on the flight to CFB
Trenton and is now in quarantine so he
traveled here to join them I'm gonna
take the appropriate precautions but
what do I want to do
it's absolutely C her 14 days sooner if
a passenger contracts coronavirus
they'll be transported off base to this
local hospital the mayor is now fielding
calls from worried residents first I
guess the concern was that they're
coming here with the virus no they're
not but many here are actually going out
of their way to welcome the new arrivals
the local grocery-store is providing
platters of food even planning a party
for when the quarantine is over there
Canadians we take care of our own that's
just what we do and it hasn't gone
unnoticed they had a lot of stuff right
there waiting in terms of diapers
clothing gloves tubes jackets you name
it they have the government says two
thirds of Canadians in Wuhan who wanted
to leave are now out and it plans to
send another plane next week to retrieve
the rest
Jeff sample Global News Trenton Ontario
now to the hundreds of other Canadians
under quarantine
tonight on to cruise ships at least
seven Canadians aboard the diamond
princess have tested positive for the
new corona virus they are now receiving
treatment thousands of other passengers
including 271 Canadians are stuck at sea
on a third cruise ship the Wester Dam is
not under quarantine but Japan is
refusing to allow the vessel to dock and
as crystal de man singh explains
passengers are left floating on
uncertainty
captain is going to allow small groups
of passengers to go out of their cabins
it's a small step but after being stuck
inside the diamond Princess cruise ship
since Monday fresh air is a luxury
diamond princess officials have now
screened passengers they believe were
potentially exposed to the virus the
Japanese Ministry of Health has advised
Princess Cruises that the quarantine
will end February 19th another ship the
Wester dam with 271 Canadians on board
is sailing off the coast of Taiwan while
it tries to secure a place to dock there
have been no reported illnesses on board
meanwhile Cruise Lines International
Association is telling all of its
members not to allow anyone to board who
has visited - or been around an airport
in Hong Kong China or Macao cruise ships
are basically in floating towns that
where everyone is is coming into close
contact with each other a thousands of
people potentially so they're a perfect
place where these types of infectious
disease outbreaks can breed in the fight
to stop the spread of the virus a 14-day
mandatory self-isolation is being
imposed in Hong Kong for all residents
arriving from mainland China anyone
caught in violation could be fined even
jailed up to six months the whole idea
is really for this person to stay at
home and not to you know go out people
are afraid of this potentially deadly
virus and they're angry tributes are
forming to honor a doctor many consider
to be among the first whistleblowers to
raise the alarm about the virus he just
tried to tell the truth today's the
regime that is allowing this virus to
spread around similar expressions on the
streets of Beijing for dr. Lee when yang
can negotiate I deeply regret his death
and feel sincerely sad for him said this
woman adding I hope he did not die in
vain
china says it will investigate the 34
year old doctors death crystal
commencing Global News London
and there's another problem emerging as
this new corona virus
bread's the World Health Organization
says there's a chronic shortage of masks
gloves and other protective equipment
there are now depleted stockpiles and
backlogs or four to six months global
stocks of masks and respirators are
insufficient to meet the needs of whu-oh
and our partners the w-h-o says part of
the reason is people who don't need to
wear the masks are buying them out of
fear they want that to stop to ensure
there are supplies for those especially
medical workers who really need them
there is big news tonight about the
pipeline project Canadian taxpayers own
the estimated cost of completing the
trans mountain pipeline expansion has
ballooned from seven point four billion
dollars to twelve point six billion
that's in addition to the more than four
billion dollars the federal government
spent to buy the project from Kinder
Morgan that brings the total investment
for taxpayers to more than 16 billion
and the project to carry more Alberta
oil to the BC coast isn't even finished
yet our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson is watching this Mercedes the
Finance Minister held a news conference
today to talk about this how does he
account for this huge jump in costs well
Donna Finance Minister Bill Morneau says
the pipeline today is dramatically
different from the project that Kinder
Morgan had planned in 2017 and while the
new number has many gasping in sticker
shock
Morneau says the increased costs mean a
better pipeline both in terms of the
build and social licence the two biggest
factors in the cost increase that he
identified changes in the pipeline's
design and the court mandated indigenous
consultations that had to take place
before it could be built the new
blueprints he says make it more
environmentally friendly and safer and
those consultations of course took time
and money as the government met with 129
indigenous groups some of whom still
oppose the project the CEO of trans
Mountain also said that these delays
were one of the biggest factors in the
increased cost
Mercedes when the prime minister made
the decision to buy the pipeline project
the idea wasn't to keep it forever but
to turn around and sell it once it was
dear it
there are proposals now to buy it
including from indigenous LED groups can
they afford to buy it now and is it
still commercially viable well those are
great questions Donna and the finance
minister and CEO of trans Mountain both
say the pipeline is still commercially
viable in part because it's already
bringing in income now remember there is
a pipeline in the ground that they're
twinning and it's expected to increase
in value when it's able to actually move
oil in its larger iteration but here's
what Bill Morneau had to say about
trying to resell it in the future and
whether or not it's viable we went
through a due diligence process to
consider how this would be commercially
viable this was in the range of
considerations that we looked at of
course the project will deliver one and
a half billion dollars of available cash
flow once it's finished which means that
it it remains commercially viable this
pipeline expansion has been promised for
years as a way to get Alberta oil out to
markets other than the US and there have
been all kinds of delays up till now now
there's five billion dollar increase
what's the latest timeline Mercedes on
when it will get built and when it might
be sold well Donna shovels are already
in the ground and they're moving forward
but as for when it will be sold that
remains to be seen the finance minister
said today that they'll sell when the
time is right and they're convinced
they'll be able to buy be able to find a
buyer even with the higher cost but who
will be willing to buy it and when that
might happen remains to be seen
all right Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa
shanks the other big decision looming
for the federal government is also in
Alberta the tech frontier oil sands mine
and tonight Alberta is warning Ottawa
not to give the province an aid package
in lieu of approving it it's a massive
proposed project just south of Wood
Buffalo National Park if approved open
pit oil sands mines would cover 24,000
hectares at peak operation it would
produce 260,000 barrels of bitumen every
day it's got all the necessary approvals
all it needs now is a yes from Ottawa
but there is plenty of pressure
including from Liberal MPs to say no as
Heather Eurex West explains the Alberta
government warned today that would be a
huge mistake with just three weeks left
until Ottawa decides the fate of a
hoes oil sands mega-project the
political rhetoric is ramping up let me
be clear from Alberta's perspective and
we have made this clear at the federal
government this will be a clear
indication on how serious the Prime
Minister is and his government - working
towards unity in this country an
independent review panel has already
recommended the twenty billion dollar
tech frontier mine proposal be approved
the company has signed agreements with
14 indigenous groups in the area but for
a government committed to achieving Net
Zero emissions by 2050 clearing the way
for a project that would increase carbon
emissions from the oil sands is
complicated the challenge that the feds
have is what does that mean to the Paris
commitments also they're taking heat
from environmentalists because they
bought trans mountain in there pushing
trans mountain through now they've got
this frontier of mine on the other side
in our view on Friday the provincial
government responded to reports that
Ottawa was considering a compensation
package for Alberta workers in the event
cabinet rejects tech but the federal
Finance Minister says no decisions have
been made the issues around tech
frontier are separate and distinct
that's going through a process that's
going to the cabinet it's unrelated to
the work that I'm doing on thinking
about how we can make sure that Alberta
continues to have a robust economy
Alberta's government is calling for the
mines approval on its own merits asking
that the project not be politicized in
any way the warning that if it's
rejected there will be a political price
to pay and Heather joins me now Heather
some other companies are abandoning
their investments in the Alberta oil
sands
I understand tech itself has not made a
final decision on whether it will even
go ahead with this project yeah that's
right tech CEO has said that even after
federal approval the project needs three
conditions to be met before the company
will go ahead it needs
TMX to be finished it needs an
investment partner and it needs oil
prices to go up so there's a very real
chance that this mega project never
moves forward approval or not but that
doesn't diminish the political stakes
here between Alberta and Ottawa Donna
all right Heather your ex west in
Calgary thanks the standoff continues
between the RCMP and protesters over the
coastal gasoline pipeline in northern BC
[Applause]
protesters say two more people were
arrested today after a tactical team of
RCMP surrounded another with so it in
blockade after yesterday's arrests the
RCMP is enforcing a court order to allow
coastal gas link workers into the region
to begin construction on the six billion
dollar pipeline which was so it an
hereditary chief suppose though elected
leaders authorized the work to go ahead
today in a show of solidarity protesters
supporting what's happening in northern
BC locked via rail traffic on a key line
in southern Ontario saying they will
back off when the RCMP leave some news
tonight about national employment levels
in Canada statistics Canada says thanks
to gains in manufacturing construction
and agriculture more than 34,000 new
jobs were added last month most of them
were in Quebec where nearly 19,000 new
jobs were created in January
in contrast Alberta lost nearly the same
amount overall the national unemployment
rate fell slightly last month to 5.5
percent it's been more than 24 hours
since a train derailment erupted into
flames coming up what's stopping
investigators from reaching the scene
oil cars from that derailed CP train and
central Saskatchewan are still burning
sending thick black smoke high into the
sky and it's preventing investigators
from reaching the site 31 cars carrying
crude oil left the tracks a dozen burst
into flames near Guernsey early
yesterday morning
the second crude oil train to jump the
tracks in that area in under two months
Canada's Transportation Safety Board is
investigating both derailments which
happened less than 10 kilometers apart
the amount of trains that are going
through and the amount of oil carried on
those trains is just it's it's
mind-boggling and really I wish they'd
get some pipelines built because
especially now when it's twice so close
to us and it could have been in town
easily Prime Minister Justin Trudeau has
arrived in Ethiopia's capital as part of
an eight-day charm campaign he's hoping
to convince African leaders to back
canada's bid for a United Nations
Security Council seat our chief
political correspondent David akin is
traveling with the prime minister and so
was someone else David well Donna that
secret weapon is Messiah jury who
basketball fans now is the president of
the reigning NBA champion Toronto
Raptors the jury joined the PM's
delegation in Ottawa made the 17 hour
journey here to addis ababa
bou giri who is nigerian join Trudeau as
he was welcomed by Ethiopian Prime
Minister Abbey Ahmed he says his role
here will be to open doors I have
relationships with leaders here and any
way we can help any way I can help it's
it's a big part of making the world
better basketball fans know a jury is
not the only African connection with the
Raptors all-star Pascal siakam is from
Cameroon senator Sarah Baca is from
Congo and forward Oh Gianna Nobby has
Nigerian roots Trudeau Amanda jury will
be here in Ethiopia until Monday that's
an unusually long stay for a Canadian
prime minister in any one country the
Trudeau plans to use that time to meet
as many of the leaders as he can from
the 54 members of the African Union
Donna all right David akin in Ethiopia
thank you I had a record downpour down
under
brings relief
you are watching global national it's
being called a bat tornado this colony
of fruit bats has invaded a small
Australian town there are about 300,000
of them in a town of just 4300 people
locals say they smell it constantly
screech and they worry the bats are a
potential health risk
Australian bats are known to carry a
rabies like disease that's transmitted
through scratches and bites though
experts say the potential to contract it
is low so much rain is falling in Sydney
Australia forecasters are warning a
potentially life-threatening flash
flooding severe weather warnings have
been issued for parts of New South Wales
with damaging winds heavy rain and
abnormally high tides expected and
Friday was the wettest day recorded in
well over a year in Sydney it's hoped
that rain will help firefighters in New
South Wales get 17 blazes under control
Antarctica has recorded its hottest
temperature on record a research station
on the northern tip of the continent
recorded a high of eighteen point three
degrees Celsius and that breaks a
previous record of 17.5 degrees in 2015
a rise of nearly one degree in five
years the Antarctic Peninsula is one of
the fastest warming places on earth
nearly all the region's glaciers are
melting scientists say it is warmed
nearly 3 degrees Celsius over the last
50 years snowstorm sequel next another
winter blast slams Atlantic Canada
snow-clearing crews in Quebec are hard
at work is a massive winter storm
Wallops the south it's shut down schools
caused hundreds of collisions and
disrupted dozens of flights this is the
biggest snowfall of the season in Quebec
up to 40 centimeters was expected to
fall today and in Atlantic Canada that
same storm system has left thousands of
homes and businesses without power and
it's made for treacherous driving
schools are closed some flights are
delayed or canceled as Ross Lord reports
people there have already had enough of
winter in northern New Brunswick 45
centimeters of snow is treated like just
another day where's this piece of canker
near your own an overnight storm also
brought freezing rain and ice buildup
but the fact is many Maritimers prefers
snow above all else I'm stomping through
the snow stuff instead of along the
icier sidewalk it took me like half hour
and I broke two my scrapers like a walk
in an icy park called off for their own
safety the preference for snow does have
its limits especially after the historic
snowfall in Newfoundland last month
which brought more than 90 centimeters
yeah it's not nearly as bad here as it
is out there
my host isn't buried so there's that I
got that going for me which is good this
storm for schools to close in all of
Nova Scotia widespread flight
cancellations and thousands of power
outages and the storms extensive reach
means it isn't over yet as far as
southern Quebec and New Brunswick we're
talking thirty to sixty centimeters of
snow and whiteout conditions on this
Friday afternoon and evening at least it
will be gone soon enough for many
Atlantic Canadians to enjoy a weekend
without any cleanup
although some refuse to let it cramp
their style even before it's over Ross
lore Global News Halifax
it is only early February that is global
national for this Friday
I'm donor freezin tonight's here Canada
is lighthouse Cove in Lake Shore Ontario
we'd love to see your Canada please
email it to viewers at global national
calm thanks for watching Robin Gill will
be here at the anchor desk over the
weekend and I will see you back here on
Monday have a lovely weekend bye-bye
[Music]
you